the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media
um and again every week thank you thank
you for giving me the opportunity to be
here every week all right if you are
watching on YouTube please hit the
Subscribe button y'all hit it just hit
your watch and hit the damn thing it's a
free way to help the show I promise you
and if you gotta have more then you
gotta check out the patreon I'm keeping
it at five dollars since day one it's
been five bucks it's gonna stay five
bucks if you sign up for a year you get
a month free
um and it's the Honeydew with you all
I'm highlighting the low lights with you
all and you all have the wildest [ __ ]
stories anyone's ever goddamn heard all
right if you or someone you know has a
story that has to be heard please submit
it to honeydew podcast gmail.com
hopefully we get to do an episode
together all right and if you are a big
fan of the Honeydew Then You're Gonna
Love my old podcast the crab feast all
the same guests that you love out there
on the podcast world uh with different
stories so if you're all caught up on
the do and you're like I'm looking for a
new podcast feasters will tell you they
got fan pages all on social media
they'll let you know they'll let you in
they'll love you all right [ __ ] the crab
feasts five stars all right that is the
business you know what we do over here
we highlight the low lights these are
the stories behind the storytellers all
right very excited to have this guest on
uh first time here on the Honeydew been
wanting to get them here for a while
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome Drew
Lynch welcome to the Honeydew Drew thank
you Ryan I could hear I could listen to
you give the business for so much longer
than that I appreciate it was so cute
like not one not one like like sputter
or nothing nothing even like just so
like I thought that I looked over a few
times I was like is there a script
there's not you're just you're just
knowing it that was good can I tell you
something first of all thank you very
much yeah I don't offer often do that
I'm not even gonna lie as I was hitting
it I was like man it feels good yeah
I'll say something dumb and I'm like
trying to poop I felt good it was good
appreciate it you make you made me feel
comfortable here good good um well
before we begin getting into your story
will you please plug promote everything
and anything you like ah thank you Ryan
first of all I love that you just make
it all about the comics up front and at
the end it's such a nice thing man
um I am doing I'm taping in San Jose the
20th and the 21st at San Jose Improv and
then I've got Austin Texas
um the the the the week after that and
those uh that's all I'm gonna plug but
the taping that's your special your
upcoming special tape and Hell yeah all
right yeah so
um social media it's just the Drew Lynch
everywhere Drew Lynch was taken when I
wanted to get it I know it sounds I
don't want that to sound more
pretentious than it is it was just like
I'll just do the Drew Lynch some people
might think it's I don't I don't need
anybody pronouncing it the it is just do
the Drew Lynch I know sometimes people
outside the
I've never had a b Vibe so let's keep it
at the Drew Lynch everywhere well let's
get to know the Drew Lynch
um I really don't know you that well
yeah you're a person I've been wanting
to get on the show we get a lot of
requests for you and I had I had dm'd
you I mean look I don't even see my DMs
people like a DMG I'm like sorry I don't
see him either but I figured out what
the hell I try I don't want to creep on
you and then we were on the show the
other night together yeah this is where
I'm gonna get it yes I'm so glad I'm so
glad too because
um I like I don't check a lot of my
socials because uh I don't know it's
like a whole mental thing you know if
you if you if you spend too much time
that you just get trapped and your day's
gone and then sometimes I don't know you
get sometimes you get Negative DMS so
that's that's my bad for not not being
able to uh follow up please yeah
um so tell me a little bit about
yourself where are you from originally
you know what will you do me a favor and
set up a little bit more pull that mic
up to you no pull the mic up to you
because I don't want people yelling at
you because yeah I can't hear you these
are the best mics in the world if you're
right on this [ __ ] yeah right here
you really you really are a dad you're
like once you set up oh yeah no he's
right he's right
[Laughter]
um I'm from uh yeah where are you from
I'm from Indianapolis
um in Indiana originally we were talking
about your about your poster in the in
the studio over there
um helium's such a good club
um and uh I so I I lived there until I
was about eight or nine and then my
family moved out to Vegas
um we all moved out to my parents wanted
to they were starting an air
conditioning company with uh my mom's
dad and so he needed help and so I moved
out to Vegas and lived there for about
10 years so I guess I kind of split my
time now outside of the strip and
everything or really close and now
outside of the strip most everybody's
pretty much outside the strip the strips
you know it's chaos and it's not
necessarily a good area so uh but yeah I
lived kind of like
just before Summerlin just before all
the rich houses like right there like I
could see all the nice houses but okay
yeah yeah that's where we live too I'm
looking at all the nice [ __ ] yeah what
are you where are you from Maryland
Maryland okay that's right that's right
okay that's why the whole all the frame
and stuff yeah that's cool man all right
so um your parents were still married
and moved out there are they still
together yeah they are wow all right I'm
finding that that's just becoming rarer
and rarer
um anytime any I mean your parents no
God I mean they were divorced my dad's
dead and they were divorced before that
oh wow yeah yeah no yeah tell me do you
have siblings yeah so I have a brother
and a sister and then and I have two
sisters one is adopted but I don't know
why I always say it that way I have a
brother and two sisters
um so yeah and I'm the oldest
um and uh and how old are you now 31.
all right you're still a baby I mean you
you still get cards uh no not not not
not recently yeah that beer bro I'm not
letting you it's yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] what your ID says I'm like nah
we're not gonna shut down we're friends
out of a pandemic I did yeah
is a pandemic baby yeah yeah I know I
did a I did I did the head shots like
recently because you have to do them
like once every however long and I did
them recently and I hate shaving for it
because I just look so so so young I
mean I look it truly it looks like
photoshopped and and everything and I
just look uh I hate it I hate it I
prefer the the the beard whatever yeah
bro thank you
um so can we talk about your injury yeah
absolutely here's the thing I didn't
know this was an injury so I just I mean
no offense I didn't dive into your past
that's okay I mean before yes of course
I mean just you know seeing you and your
clips and stuff and I thought that you
were born or developed early on a speech
impediment yeah stutter and that you had
this thing your whole life and I come to
find out that this is an injury and then
I'm starting to think like whoa holy
[ __ ] so at some point it Dawns on you
this is never going away at some point
you have to learn the a new pattern I'm
assuming you probably no letters that
maybe you're better at or so I have a
million [ __ ] questions first of all
walk us through that day what happened
uh sure yeah so
um oh man it always is hard to like I
feel like I've you know you know you
sometimes you do press on the road and
stuff and they'll ask you about it and
you give like some Abridged version but
what I really can appreciate about like
the tone of the the tone of your Vibe
and the tone of this show is like that
you get to like you know re re remember
and relive a lot of those details you
know like things that you know uh I
don't ever really go through the
emotional sort of uh uh uh re
remembering or the emotional sort of uh
uh uh impact that that that time had on
me because I just I've been so familiar
with it for however long and told it for
so long but
um it was 11 years ago and I was working
at a comedy club I was working at
Flappers in Burbank I was the door guy
never to do stand up like I didn't I
never wanted to do it and uh but did you
think you could that even then I tried I
tried but I bombed real real good enough
to be like never [ __ ] around yeah
well here's the thing is like it was the
perfect night job for me because I could
uh uh have my days free to do um acting
stuff so I moved out here to be an actor
I went to a Performing Arts middle
school performing arts high school and
um I just I you know I really kind of
loved that whole world so public
speaking was never a thing being in
front of crowds was never a thing for me
um
um so we they had a pickup softball game
there and uh they every week I went
and then this was like a year after I
lived here I already had uh
representation acting wise with uh a
pretty pretty reputable agency and a
good manager and I had some appointments
lined up some callbacks for those
appointments I already I look young now
I mean 11 years ago 12 years ago I
looked even younger obviously so I was
booking like a lot of stuff for like uh
for Disney and I had some stuff lined up
for like uh like uh like like Mad Men
and some did like uh Nickelodeon stuff
and like uh How I Met Your Mother like
some guest and you know some so some
stuff for me that like I was so excited
about the momentum of of that and then
just being around stand up being such a
fan of like what it is that
stand-ups do and like it just kind of
felt
um it just felt like next to it you know
just being like Oh I'm in it and stand
up and is still in the in the in the OR
same Arena as like uh
acting and Performing and so
um I played baseball growing up and I
played uh so I elected to play shortstop
um and uh and um that one of the days I
remember it was like a Sunday and that
following week I had a a bunch of uh
like I had like casting director
meetings and just a bunch of I just
remember that week I I was like on cloud
nine because I just felt so
um like I just I don't know it never
happens that quick in people's in in in
this industry and for me it might not
have but at the same time it still felt
like I was really making a lot of
momentum and building it so uh that
Sunday
um they it was just a grounder it was
just a ground ball that it got hit my
way and sometimes you play these you
play softball and sometimes these guys
like they come up and smack the [ __ ] out
of it you know what I mean like we
played we played like the the burbet
that game I think was the Burbank fire
department and so every and it's co-ed
so that we've got the Burbank fire
department okay so in a wreck before
yeah and those guys I watched one of
them they ran over a lady in the plate
I'm not kidding
I know exactly and they told us too we
played basketball against them too they
told us they're gonna foul the [ __ ] out
of you and they said I swear on my God
okay I played at a wreck basketball
league
yeah they said it
if you call fouls on them they'll
[ __ ] ticket you on the way home and
[ __ ] they'll follow you and tickle you
and these refs were letting them
Slaughter us and you can't do anything
back you can't punch the cop on the
court yeah
ah yeah they're brutal man so we played
so yeah we so and they I mean and we're
like you know it's like a slappers team
I'm on the flappers team none of us we
none of us know what the [ __ ] I mean
none of us know what the [ __ ] we're
doing and um
and it uh so it popped up I it just took
a weird hop like I've got a good
hand-eye coordination or maybe I maybe I
used to or maybe I thought I did but I
thought like it it popped up it hit me
and um I fell back and went go on the
ground so I literally and I later found
out only recently found out that because
of due to CTE brain scan and all that
[ __ ] my brain my brain in my head went
back and then forward it physically
should do it so I had
like bruising like a traumatic brain
injury on on on my brain from that and
the whole time
you know the diagnosis that they gave me
was a minor vocal contusion with a major
concussion people a million times said
that to me you have a minor vocal
contusion with a major concussion
because the the that day I that day I
was scheduled to go to work after the
game and after that play I only remember
the I don't remember any of the events
that day I only remember what people
have told me about that the events that
night and then the following morning so
that night apparently I had gone to uh
back to the club to do my shift yeah and
then there yeah I gone back to the club
to do this but they you do own Flappers
now yeah yeah yeah I have it
I've made no money from it
I yeah it's uh yeah so I um so you don't
even remember this but you went back to
work they released yeah so we'll yeah
they released me once in the hospital
not from there now so I went to I went
back to work they were like hey you're
kind of out of it went back home someone
just had told you they noticed that you
were that enough yeah they were like you
I just think you just need to like sleep
it off and then yeah
and then so I went home went to sleep
and I woke up and I just remember my
roommate was like crying I remember he
was like crying at the sink and I
couldn't I couldn't really remember
much else from that day but I remember
later that day I was in the hospital my
parents they were still in Vegas at the
time they're back in Indiana now but
they were in Vegas at the time they flew
um and and saw me that night in the in
the hospital and
um I remember I don't even remember the
the amount of doctors that came through
to see me but it was like all right
we're flying somebody else in from Vegas
we're uh uh Vegas has a uh Vegas has a
good um
like they have a good unit uh uh I can't
remember what the college is that's in
Vegas but it's like UNLV yes yeah UNLV
that's right uh UNLV had somebody that
they flew in and then they had like a
like a like a ear nose and throat and
then they had like a pathologist come
see me in a neurologic neurologist come
see me and uh basically when they ran
all this the scans and did all the tests
they were like listen this is this is
what it is uh but it's something that I
it's something that should your my
speech used to be much worse and they're
like it should come back um in a short
time they were like it should come back
in in about a month which is such a
weird number
um so in that time
um I uh remember writing down a lot of
the feelings that I was having not never
to really talk about it on stage but
just like hey this is crazy like stuff
that's happening to me I remember
writing down a lot of the stuff and when
in the few days that I was in the
hospital uh uh on a napkin
um and just to kind of to try to process
what was happening because you really
like I was like this is at that I
remember when when I was starting to
feel like myself again I was like this
is crazy I don't think this will ever
manifest it's I don't think it'll
manifest itself or manufacture itself
into something worse and of course
Famous Last thoughts I guess
um so uh so yeah it was just kind of
like the point you're still speaking
normally and stuff no no no no no no the
next morning the next morning I woke up
everything was that day the rest of that
day yes but the next morning the rest of
that day every the rest of the day my my
speech is fine but apparently my
thoughts are just not but the next day
is when my speech I I can't even
recreate it but it used to be like it
like it like I had a I had a vocal issue
and just my the connectivity of from my
thoughts to my mouth was not working and
I could I wasn't even able to like do
this really my motor skills were all did
it hurt was it painful no no no nothing
was so full nothing was painful oh I
just remember getting so tired like even
the the weeks after I mean for years I
was just so tired
so
the stutter then is not from the ball
striking the chords it's from the
violent brain Shake yeah is that right
yeah so this really was just a contusion
yeah yeah and I thought it was true I
thought it was for a really long time
but it was like no your voice just your
voice your the you need to learn how to
speak properly with your vocal cords
moving together again because once you
have this idea that once you are her and
you have this idea that you're hurt uh
and your and your vocal cords are you if
not you you have this in your brain
that's like oh this just this just
doesn't work and it's like speech
therapy is so good at like being like no
you have to constantly remind yourself
this can work this can come back you
have to just re-learn the mechanics of
that
listen I'm over here I boohoo about it
all the time but this I've I've had no
smell well not no smell for two years
I've lost my smell because of Cove in
December 2020. and I maybe have 10 of it
back
um but the things don't like a cigarette
I know what a cigarette smells like now
it does not though tons of weed that I
smoke that you saw me smoke and it goes
right under my nose can't smell it wow
can't smell for bathroom stinks trash
like things like that and then I think
about things like this like you know
they say
um you know you think about your own
problems and if we all were to throw
them in a circle we'd take our own back
yeah right so
you immediately start I would trade you
though you would trade me
yeah you would would you though think
about that listen what you've been able
to do with this like how you've been
able to overcome
um would you well there's a thing hang
on so I I feel like I can get into this
with you please because well first of
all is this too heavy already hell okay
because I don't know I don't know
I mean no subconscious but yeah you
shouldn't we've had people come on this
show and talk about rape talk about
physical abuse from their parents well
I'll guide all that too
[Laughter]
well then maybe it is
damn you can pick and pick up on that
Ryan you can smell my rape story coming
all right sorry no no jokes about rate
but
um so I I have a I have a uh I have a I
would say
tumultuous relationship with my with my
speech because of the amount of
um
ridicule and uh
social sort of
um
dissonance that I felt and and how I was
distanced and sort of felt kind of
isolated because of it and uh early on
not at all really thinking this was
going to be my trajectory feeling very
much like woe is me and embellishing
like this actually doesn't ruined yeah
like exactly a victim mindset not and
you know it's it everything happens
every some everything happens to
everyone so feeling like you can only be
sad about it can only get you so far and
you can only do it for so long which by
the way I think it is healthy to be like
listen this sucks and I'm in a shitty
spot right now address it and then you
gotta do what you can to get out of it
um or or embrace it and and you know you
can you can try to get out of your
situation for so long before you're like
all right I have a lot to learn from
this I'm gonna use it to to what I can
to still let my light shine or let let
me express myself despite my
circumstances and
you know when I first started uh I I I
Revisited all those notes that I wrote
down on the napkin you know trying to go
on go on stage with uh uh I had gotten a
lot of encouragement from Comics who
were over at Flappers who were like
listen you got to use what happened to
you talk about it talk about it and so
the first time I went on stage I um you
know uh it wasn't like good jokes I
wouldn't say it wasn't like uh you know
like it's never like whatever and that's
the first time I went on stage post
injury prior to injury I went on stage
two times I bombed so hard and just I
was like all right well it's not for me
and that's fine I can still admire other
comics and doing it and I you know you
know I'll still be within my acting
Pursuits and so
um when that happened
um uh I got so much overwhelming support
from Comics at the mic like yes there
was yes there's some audience but mostly
it was just comics and it just it really
felt good
to feel like okay these are a group of
Misfits that have their own
um eclectic I would say uh that they
they have a it's a group of people who
have their own uh failures or loss or
pain or whatever that they're using some
maybe not but a lot of them that's what
they're doing it for and so it did kind
of feel good to feel accepted by Comics
even though every single person that
continued to walk through the door when
I was working at Flappers because I
still work there afterwards
um uh you know you don't you don't I had
to check people in I had to take their I
had to take their information people
would look at me like is this a bit
people look at me like you know like I'm
not giving like this is taking too I
just want to go to the [ __ ] show and
I yeah but but but but but but I
remember my boss at the time you know at
the time she was so like you got to get
everybody's information you got to do
this and like so I just I and sometimes
feeling like that line starting to line
up I actually think I helped flapper's
business to be honest when people see a
line people are like what's going on
tonight
then you definitely helped their
business
okay
no they were they were they were you
know I always did wonder if they if they
ever didn't let me go because you know
because I don't know but they pay your
medical bills no no but it wasn't it
wasn't on company it wasn't on company
property and and here and here's the
thing like it was like it was a it was a
bill man and I didn't I'm sure I didn't
make money doing stand-up for until like
four years after that and so I was I was
on you know I was on a I was just doing
a night job working there and you know I
was happy to have stage time but all
those bills I was just like I'll worry
about that later but anyway so I did the
mic I did the mic and I and I just I
felt like oh man like uh
um I felt just like I could express
myself like my life like my light's not
out you know what I mean like I I'm not
I'm not I'm not sunk yet I haven't
drowned so it fell you know being in
performing on in any Avenue in any way I
think is like a a really really
cool thing at least for me and I think a
necessary uh thing for a lot of com
comics and um that happened and so in a
way it really taught me that uh I taught
me a few things one that I could have
support from uh people who I I didn't
know that I could get support from and
two it taught me that being vulnerable
is a good thing
um and then three it taught me
um uh word economy and brevity and my
when your speech is so slow uh you
really have to save the very last few
words to change the whole context of the
joke and so I just I wrote every single
day so much and just trying to cut and
edit and edited editing is my favorite
part of stand up probably because of
that and you know even we're talking
about your special where we're just you
know you're like oh I want to pull this
and I want to use this part I know that
this I know that this this bit has a
place in my hour but I know I'm gonna
move it somewhere in the center and I
know and even doing that on a more
microscape scale where you can do that
with jokes like truly if I don't
advocate for myself well but I think I
am a good editor and that's my skill set
like I just think when it comes to yeah
writing fine performing okay but when it
comes to editing that's when I think I
really really shine and I think that's
because I attribute that to my injury
all right I have three questions I'm
dying to ask and I'm gonna say them so I
don't forget okay okay okay one I want
to talk about when you had to mentally
accept Okay this shit's not going away
and this is not only my profession but
how I need to communicate on a
day-to-day yeah I want to ask you about
writing specifically in stand up yeah if
you
I know that speaking
um just
casually whatever off the cuff is you
know it is what it is but if you're
writing stand up and you can rehearse it
in your mind can you do a set without
um stuttering yeah I mean if I ever
heard I've gotten so much better at it
now I've just gotten so much more
confident it's like okay
and sometimes I feel like sometimes like
you know you're talking about those
things where you say you I you know
little little words and letters that I
know that I have these triggers people
who stutter we all do this and that
we're always thinking ahead to things
that that we get stuck on so like that's
what's that's what I don't want to say
right yeah exactly wow you're
circumventing all the time because and
that's that's hard I think that that
contributes a lot to this vicious cycle
because you get so much anxiety not from
not from just the stutter but it's also
because I can't sometimes be fully in
this conversation with you I hear you
and you can't you let you miss human
connect connection you miss human
connection because you're you're
literally directing your life all the
time
and sorry I know I'm getting like
emotional but it's just it's it's it's
it's something that like
I I have so much anxiety all the time
because I'm I'm I'm thinking all the
time about the way that I say things and
not not necessarily just what I want to
say and I I envy people who like they
they're you sometimes you can just see
people they're they're all exterior
their heart is just everywhere and and
and and and you you they they say
something and it's imperfect and somehow
it's still so awesome because that's
just who they are for me I'm constant
now I think that is also why it's such a
strength of mine is because I'm
constantly doing it I'm constantly in my
head about the way something goes or how
it goes a different way and and oh and
what I was gonna what I was gonna say
because I want to answer your questions
okay yeah what I was gonna say is that's
why my relationship with my speech has
been so tumultuous because I I used it
initially to make self-deprecating jokes
to really heal and then because I've
gotten so much progress over my speech
and then I had success with my speech
people now criticize the legitimacy of
it and if and and if and if
my whole for year I get it now I did I
did America's Got Talent almost eight
years ago and my speech was way
different than than it is now and
consistently worked on it we've worked
on it no one sees my medical bills no
one sees the the amount of professional
medical professionals you and I talking
before the before the things that that
whole season for Flappers don't that was
the only error you made man
you're a [ __ ] Gold Glove out there
shortstop
ah
that was the Lone Arrow a gold glove
Burbank Police Department and fire
department would have been loved to have
you out there in short run
was it against the Burbank Police
Department it was fire department man
everybody owes you money bro
I've owned rappers that Parks and Rec I
own Birdman [ __ ] man
I know I wanted Glendale but Burbank
will be fine the new year is here and
there's no better way to kick off 2023
than by making sure you're feeling like
your best self liquid IV is the category
winning hydration brand fueling your
well-being and their hydration
multiplier is the one product you're
missing in your daily routine
tangerine's my favorite flavor it's
going to tell you that right off the top
keep them here at the studio at this
point now I just keep a bottle in the
car drop that liquid IV in it take a
bottle of the gym there's liquid IV in
it wherever that water is there's liquid
Ivy in it one stick of liquid Ivy and 16
ounces of water hydrates you two times
faster more efficiently than water alone
it contains five essential vitamins B3
B5 B6 B12 and vitamin C with three times
the electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks it's made with premium
ingredients there's non-GMO and it's
free from gluten dairy and soy grab your
liquid IV and bulk nationwide at Costco
or you can get 20 off when you go to
liquid iv.com use code honeydew at
checkout that's 20 off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code honeydew at
liquid iv.com now let's get back to the
do
um so anyway what are your so yes tell
me so yeah another question I do have
before I ask you about we can't just
bring in more questions
write these down um do you have a
stutter when you talk to yourself when
you dream no no when I no usually when
I'm around people that I get really
really comfortable with and I'm
comfortable with myself
um I I don't and it's getting like I
said like your inner monologue is not no
no I hear it it is truly when it starts
to happen you're like don't do that and
then and and then but that break has
gotten I think of it as like a break
like an actual pedal I it's gotten like
softer you almost have to go against
that instinct to do that and not be hard
on yourself for when it happens and the
less that I've catered the less that I
that I start better is your voice same
bass same octave or at any of that
change I think it gets higher because I
get more stressed when I come from
before the injury yeah it was higher so
sorry sorry sorry my voice was lower but
it was it after my injury it was higher
my voice now is more close to how I was
speaking then but if I really think
about it I use a lot of breath support
it gets into this register which is my
usual register but when I get excited or
I get nervous or anything it goes up
into a higher thing and then that's when
it's you know whatever but that's almost
anybody
so does do you mean then that when
you're actually doing stand-up because
stand up is a very just by definition
it's a selfish [ __ ] thing it's us
talking at a crowd to a crowd not with
um does that more freeing for you then
do you feel more comfortable in that
hour there because you don't have to
worry about what anybody else is gonna
[ __ ] say it's you're in 100 control
this this that for me is something that
I only realize later it's like I have
all this it's in this you have this
weird dynamic with an audience where
it's like I need you but I have so much
resentment for you because outside of
the heater you would treat me this way
the meet and greet ain't gonna be like
this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
one yeah 100 100 and and you have to
have I I've gotten this through just a
lot of exploring and just meditating on
it but you know I've gotten a healthier
relationship in my relationship with
people now where it's like I feel like I
want to be a service to them where it's
not I wear I've almost removed myself
more from the selfish component and
seeing and now seeing myself is like how
is it can I get if how is it that I can
give something to you and even people
who have like had been critical or or or
My stand-up might not be for them or
they might question if my speech is my
impediment is real I still try to give
the grace of that and be like how is it
that I can still offer a service and
that to me shows that to me it feels
like that's what Grace is supposed to be
and so there's a been almost a free or a
feeling in that in that I feel more
levity in my stand-up lately even around
comics I used to get so like if I would
be in the room with like with Bill or
with Eliza or anybody if I was in the
room with them I couldn't I almost
couldn't even talk like I I remember
when I first met Bill he came to do
Flappers and the manager had me sell his
CDs with him and he's like leaning on
the counter I'm stuttering so bad and
I'm trying to sell his CTS and Bill
you know so like I can tell he's
laughing because of the situation he's
in he's like he's not saying anything
he's just going yeah and he goes uh you
don't have to do that
I'll never forget it I'm impressed I
mean I'm impressed for how long he
didn't say something because his body
language was saying I'm saying so many
things in my head despite leaning on the
counter that that that classic Bill
leaning on the counter kind of thing but
I just I was so I was so that was
humiliating dude Ryan I cannot tell you
I was sorry I'm I'm meeting this is the
first time I'm meeting them and I'm
selling a CD I'm trying to sell his CDs
and he just goes in such a gracious way
he's like you don't have to he didn't
even finish
[Laughter]
you know
you know just oh it's too good that was
too good ah all right so so yeah that
make as a performer that completely
makes sense to me I felt that when you
were saying that like yeah this is real
freedom in this this all right so can we
talk about like just in life like when
you realized [ __ ] this thing's not going
away like when you actually have to
mentally accept that yeah and then start
learning a new pattern of speech and a
new way of talking yeah that's like I
said that's a whole new ball game which
I'm sure it's there's some depression uh
in there and and also acceptance and
then like you said there's gratitude
later but all that doesn't come unless
you go through the [ __ ] absolutely all
the stages of grief absolutely and it
sounds you know it sounds whatever lame
or meta or or I don't know selfish but
it truly is it truly is it was the
stages of grief and when you're going
through it sometimes you're not aware
care that that's what's happening I
would say almost most times you're not
aware that that's what's happening and I
was 20 what 20 when that happened so you
know I was 20 years old when the injury
happened and you know
um it took me I would say it I would say
for a few years it was taking me some
time to really cope with the fact that
this was probably probably my reality
for the rest of my life that was my new
house a couple years yeah yeah yeah I
mean yeah because you have you you when
you get off stage from a set when you
get done when you do a set and it goes
well you're like I don't even care you
know I don't even whatever if all that
has if all this had to happen so I can
feel this great feeling of being like ah
I'm expressing myself people are
commiserating with me about my
circumstance
but then an hour later when you're at
home and you're by yourself and you're
whatever you're single or you go to a
restaurant and ordering's tough or
you're back in the [ __ ] of being a a
person in this situation you're that
super power is late is where is it's
late it's not as it's not as much now
you're like you are uh you just feel oh
I'm so so human now I'm so
um flawed and I would say you know I
talked about this when I did America's
Got Talent compassion wasn't something
that I was like I wasn't like the most
compassionate person with other people I
wasn't by any means like the worst
person I just a compassion was something
that it took a back seat to a lot of my
situations because I was just selfish
and I think I'm still selfish but
this this speech issue really forced me
to take a look at a lot of my other
issues and realize that I'm human
because I'm imperfect and whatever so
um so yeah yeah I I forget what question
I was answering there but I was
answering just sorry the acknowledgment
to yourself yeah hey this is the way
it's going to be yes yeah and so yeah
and so sorry I lost track there but I
just mean I just mean like
um yeah for a few years it was me
realizing that this was how this was how
it was going to be and when I lost
America's Got Talent I you know I it was
me and the last guy and when I lost I
didn't realize until I lost I was using
that experience as a coping mechanism
for what had happened to me I was like
if if if I win this show then it all
will have made sense and I'll be fine
and we're always saying that to
ourselves anyway in this business if I
get this this will be I'll be happy yeah
if I get this
but that really was I I just didn't even
realize it until afterwards and I kept
telling myself it's fine I'm just happy
that I get to be doing this and I'm glad
that I get to keep advancing but only
way after the fact that I realize that I
was using that as an experience to try
and validate my my my injury why do you
think you did that
as a way of was it also something that
you thought could help your career too
oh sure yeah sure yeah absolutely I knew
I know yeah I knew that it could but but
if I knew that I if I could if
everything and all the [ __ ] that had
happened and all the work that I put in
not just uh personally but also
professionally in in embarking on now a
stand-up pivot
um it would at least make sense it would
at least be able to validate okay maybe
in the ethers of the universe or the the
plan or the blueprint of my life makes
sense this had to happen so this could
happen yeah yeah
and it didn't and it it's once something
that again only hindsight can give you
the the appreciation for can I ask you
this though do you really think winning
would have no it was a blessing yeah it
absolutely was a blessing that would
have that would have
um delayed or belabored you know me
addressing maybe some issues but they
would have came up again and at a
different time and also something that I
think it taught me was okay everything's
gonna have to be up to me afterwards and
most people think that I built my
audience from that show like yeah yeah I
was on it and it did well for me and
maybe people might know me from that but
I had to sustain and build uh I built
most of everything that I built after
that show it wasn't you know from a
number standpoint from a sales
standpoint from anything I built it all
afterwards which you know you can
attribute to you can attribute to I
think um me also just feeling like ah
all right that that's that's that lesson
is like you sure you put all your eggs
in the basket of just this experience
hoping that it's gonna pay off for you
and then realizing that
um it'll be up to you to it's it's gonna
just be up to you to put things in your
hands you know
but also even if you win that it's the
same yeah it really is in the end it's
true it's all in your hands after that
absolutely this whole thing is
absolutely so what do you
um can I ask you about speech patterns
and things like that like ask me
whatever what's what do you struggle
with the most um words words that start
with the same letter back to back and
H's or H's are pretty tough so
obliteration is not alliteration yeah
and incidentally that's the thing that
um
um they have you work on the most in
speech is truly like tongue twisters and
like you know that's really figuring
yeah and then there's this easy onset
finding the resonant um there there's
resonant sounds that I'm always aware of
in every word because you're supposed to
gravitate towards those words that or at
least the sounds within those words that
are helpful for your speech that most
people aren't even aware in fact I've
done so much speech therapy I can tell
when someone else is not speaking
correct exactly yeah but you know I'll
bet you know and so
um but I think I've gotten it's like I
said like you know the second time I
meet you and the third time I meet you
and when I see you around the scene it's
gonna be you know it's just it's gonna I
know it's gonna be better because I will
have felt comfortable not just in not
just in us meeting but in how vulnerable
you let me be with you I never talk this
way with pretty much any comic or
anybody I'm I would say I'm pretty
introverted but you know it it's it's
one of those things that like you know
around my wife like I'm it's it's so
easy and it's just you know I've easily
said words like like edit edited before
when I'm around her sometimes I can just
nail that yeah yeah I'm throwing an
extra Ed and I'm like edited I can't
okay as I'm saying and so there's a clip
out there that a few years ago went like
stupid viral for whatever reason where
someone had me try to someone asked why
I tried to say I tried to say the word
banana and that one's always so tough
for me because of the the tongue and
then and so that went like really really
viral and so then a lot out of people
started showing up at my shows and they
would bring me like they would bring me
little stuff you know like just it
became like a thing and so uh that's one
of those things that like I said like
the maturity not not that I'm referring
to myself as mature but the process of
maturing past being like okay I am
basically a clown for for the purposes
of you giggling we are yes we are for
you laughing at how much this is
actually painful for me during the day
but at the same time you can appreciate
that you can find and meet people who
want who who do have humor in that and
are lighthearted enough to you know and
so then it became a thing that like uh a
lot of people will shout that out or
they'll ask me to say it or do they come
up to after and yeah people who stutter
or anything like that or my stuff or a
lot I get a lot of parents who are like
my son sutters and you're this when I
when I was after uh after my injury
actually after I after I did America's
Got Talent is when I started to really
go to a lot of um support groups where
it's a lot of younger kids and I go to
Camp say that's a that's a any of them
from an injury like yourself some a lot
of adults a lot of adults okay yeah a
lot of adults car car accidents adult
onset stuff violence adult onset
stuttering is something that that
happens sometimes people have it from
Strokes sometimes people have it
um inexplicably they just wake up and
then that that's that's just what
happens so but I would say a lot of it
is in adolescence mostly boys like five
to seven sometimes it's girls mostly
boys and I just you know I look at my
situation and comparing it to theirs
like they have to like find out who they
are while they're growing up and like
there's these parents who they just they
they're they're like they're crying and
they're telling me they're just like I
just don't know what to do or I'm I just
you know he comes home and he he's
crying every day and it's just like you
know I I I I don't consider myself to be
like whatever the uh stuttering
Ambassador but I feel like it is somehow
you're armed with this level of
responsibility that goes beyond on I
guess just what it is that you do and
it's interesting because I've gotten
I've gotten so much I've built so much
resentment for my speech because so many
people will message me and or and be
like I miss when you did I miss when you
did stutter I miss you know I I and it's
like it's crazy because how could you
say like you want you want to put a
ceiling over my personal growth for your
for your enjoyment you know for I missed
when you have both your legs yeah
exactly yeah yeah yeah
exactly so it's like you know so it's
just it's it's one of those things that
I think um you know you just you just
try to take away the ground can you go
on like a laced cursed tirade and not
cuss or stutter excuse me yeah like
where do you cursing is easy without
stuttering yeah that's that that like if
you what how many curse you ever tried
to do a curse back to back to back
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] ass tits [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
all out of I'm out of that's all I know
damn it
um what are your strengths when it comes
to the speech pattern
um curse words obviously yeah curse
words are good I think like you know
there's a melodic intonation technique
which is uh basically singing say you've
heard about that people who stutter they
don't when they sing I know is that
right you don't so if you sang your
instructions to your wife you wouldn't
yeah I mean it would be annoying as [ __ ]
yeah exactly yeah exactly yeah exactly
exactly so it's like no I'll just stick
with stuttering
um it's better than the alternative
that's interesting I didn't know about
the singing yeah so that's a technique
that's actually a very
um researched and I would say effective
technique is
yeah I mean I've watched I also started
doing this when when Steve Harvey had
that interview where he was like every
single day I stand in the mirror I give
myself affirmations I walk across the
room while talking to myself out loud
and that has been something like you
would never know Steve Harvey Steve
Harvey Ed Sheeran uh Paul Rudd like you
all these people you have no idea
um that they did they did what shuttered
oh really they all did yeah okay yeah
and they were able to work rehabilitate
it in some way or another and um you
know uh I just think it's the there is I
think an inherent
um vicious cycle which is the more you
try to focus on uh not doing something
then you do I mean but that that
principle applies to almost anything you
know you say like when I get home I'm
not gonna eat like [ __ ] and then you do
that immediately so anyway
um but I feel like you know and it's
like even around comics like I I I
sometimes I sometimes like when I watch
when I watch you perform for the first
time at the store I thought I could
never and this is not just for you this
is almost for anybody but I watch you I
watch you perform in the belly room for
the first time I was like oh man he's so
funny
um uh I would love yeah yeah I was like
oh man he's so funny I would love to be
able to walk over and say like good set
and introduce myself talk easily just
you know and even though my stutter is
like so much better it's like it it's
night and day from what it was I feel
just that's that social part that social
where you just you're stressing about
what should what you hope not to happen
and you know I'm just I'm thinking a
million things I'm thinking will I I'm
thinking will he will will it matter if
I don't stutter that's a thing now like
where I'm like oh I didn't stutter at
all and and and and and when people or
if I get through a full thing and people
will go uh hey man you sound great right
now and then it's like oh [ __ ] now I'm
thinking about you know I know I'm
thinking about it even though I sounded
great but I would say like I keep going
back to this um template which is you
know I just care less and less and I I'm
hoping that other people will also care
uh less and less
well let me know if I'm boring the [ __ ]
I don't know any of this because are you
kidding me I've got a million questions
I'm filling up okay I um well I I met
you at The Improv the other night and
like I said Your name's been on our
board back there for a while because
I've wanted to have you on
um
but there was no way I wasn't going to
come up to the other night but listen
I'm the same way I'm not uh
I'll sit and talk to you if you come up
and talk to me but I'm probably not
going to go over to you and have a heart
to heart outside of a hey how you doing
or whatever I'm just not that person
I've never been that person yeah like
once you sort of crack the nut I'll sit
there and tell you everything yeah that
kind of [ __ ]
um is that the way you are are you
that's are you someone who you I you
would identify yourself as an extrovert
or an introvert I it's funny you ask
that yeah
um during the pandemic I realized how
extroverted I was because of what we do
and I missed being around but I don't
need to be so I'm I'm an introverted
extrovert does that make any [ __ ] yes
it does that's what I realize I am like
I can go sit by myself and have dinner
but I like to be around the people I
like I'm comfortable going to a movie by
myself a concert a sporting event I'm
comfortable
um being on stage in front of 300
[ __ ] people yeah and not really
outside of the meet and greet like
hanging out with them for hours on end
or talking to them about yeah that [ __ ]
I I don't know well that's what I would
say is I've noticed about you is that
you're you're so even keeled like you're
the same right when you go on stage
right when you come off stage it's the
same and and that's that's to me also
where I'm in my head about like oh man
like he's got like a Cool vibe I I
probably don't want to bother him or
whatever and so you just you know uh you
you make assumptions about people and
none of it's negative but sometimes it
can be wrong and you know learning so
much about you today like just talk
talking before the podcast and now and
like you know it's just I I I I I get a
fuller picture of your of your of your
of your Vibe and the essence of the way
that you that you are you like my
Essence I do what's up I do thank you I
think it's I think it's I think it's
sincere it is sincere
um and the other thing too we talk about
with comedians all the time is it's like
unless we're on a show together like The
Improv or The Comedy Store or at a
festival we don't see each other it's a
solo sport we're out there traveling uh
my producer Kirsten goes with me a lot
and I was like you'll see we're gonna
see all we've seen Mark Maron Mazda
brawny Eddie Brahman we see them all in
the airport crossing paths with each
other like there's another one where are
you going Annie Letterman I'm like yeah
she's coming back from here we're going
there you know
um so yeah it's also these podcasts are
a nice way to sit down and you know not
[ __ ] on any other ones but we're not
movie reviewing or whatever I'm getting
to know who the [ __ ] you are I'm not
asking you to come on here and be joking
funny yeah and I'm asking you to [ __ ]
tell me what's really going on there and
they're and that's what I like that's
why I was so like I was excited to to to
learn about this podcast uh and the way
you and the way it's ran there's no
pressure to feel like it's that and I
don't think that that's me to be honest
I think that you know when I first met
when I first met my wife she told me
um she told me she expect like because
she's seen me perform before did you
meet her before or after you had the
stutter uh after after yeah so that my
stutter was over a decade ago and then
uh
uh we I've been dating her for about
five years okay
um so uh she was just like you she said
to me you're so much uh you're so much
you're so much deeper than I thought
like I just thought it would be you know
jokey all the time when it's it's
actually you know I would say I'm
80 this all the time and then maybe 20
is and that's I agree you know that's
that's almost 75-25 yeah yeah I mean I
like to find humor in as many moments as
I can yeah I've never I've never hung
out with or could take the person that
was on 24 7. yeah like there's also what
you're not getting to do is know that
real [ __ ] person so all we're doing
is meeting this representative of you 24
7. can we sit down and have a real
[ __ ] moment here about some [ __ ]
absolutely absolutely I mean a lot of
comedians I again this show you would
ask me why before we recorded it would
call it the Honeydew and I'll tell you
but this show has made me
reappreciate comedians in such a
different way to listen to people like
yourself and these people to come on and
share these horrific [ __ ] stories and
yet still find light yeah you know
laughter levity in these moments like
that's what this show is and I The
Comedians are unlike most [ __ ] people
yeah most people are like how the [ __ ]
are you laughing at that yeah that's
crazy and I'm like that's another way of
dealing with [ __ ] but the Honeydew
um and I say it a lot but the um I'm
having dinner at this Diner one night
they they bring my food and they bring
that [ __ ] fruit cup and
um I eat everything in it but the
Honeydew right I even ate those the ugly
red grapes I like green grapes but I
hate the red one and and I don't have
this like I don't I didn't go into it
with like honeydew it's not something I
just don't [ __ ] with it it's just it's
like iceberg lettuce you know what I
mean it's the fruit equivalent and um I
get up and I leave and I see honeydew on
the [ __ ] table tops everywhere and I
just thought to myself you know what
that sucks that's a perfectly good fruit
that just gets tossed aside and then I
realized that that's who I am in life
in this perfectly fine person oh my face
too you but somebody wants to throw
their sandwich that's brilliant and then
I just wanted to start talking about you
know and the other thing too is Drew
everybody we see these [ __ ] it's
everybody's social media is their
highlight reel it's their ESPN you know
here's the best moments of my life but
it's 30 [ __ ] seconds at a time yeah
there's 24 hours in a day you know what
I mean so I also wanted to talk about
what's really going on behind all that
[ __ ] on social media and what's really
going on in your life between that
minute clip of you in you know being
ecstatic at the top of this mountain
peak or whatever the [ __ ] it is yeah
um and thankfully people really enjoy it
and like it and this is you're going to
get a lot of love this is not in any way
boring or too depressing or dark believe
me yeah well that's I mean that's super
interesting because again I thought you
were born with this and you learned how
to be a performer and everything which
also is like you've had to overcome two
things
just being a comedian in itself and
learning how to be a public speaker I
know I'm I go back and listen to old
[ __ ] of mine sometimes I'm like who you
sound like a [ __ ] caveman you know
what I mean like God and I thought I was
okay you know and then I hear myself
that in 10 years I listen I'm like God
you're podcast
[Laughter]
um so how is it with your wife
um she's great uh we got we got married
this Summer and um uh she is a world
champion in cross-country skiing and get
the [ __ ] out here A World Champ yeah for
the U.S now for Bulgaria but she's she's
been for Bulgaria and for us yeah and
she is trying to she's training right
now to qualify for the next cross
country training is that uh do you feel
like [ __ ] next to her oh yeah yeah I
mean she's got to be in the best shape
yeah she's yeah she's crazy
she eats and it doesn't even matter
her dad was uh like number two or number
three in the world for skiing uh uh uh
in Bulgaria at one point so yeah it's
cross country you don't have to get out
a gun and shoot and all that stuff
yeah but she's out she's out there in
Vermont right now and all and a lot of
her friends are by athletes and like
world champion like uh and and olymp and
Olympic uh medalists in in that and
um it's pretty it's pretty insane but
she's just genetically she just has like
and also she works incredibly hard but I
just mean genetically she's just one of
those metabolisms that like she you know
pasta three times a day like it doesn't
matter you know what I mean how old is
she she's 26. I mean that helps too yeah
well yeah but I mean even still like how
did you guys meet how do you mean yeah I
did a I did a show in Vermont and then
after the show we I went to uh I went to
the bar and uh there she ordered uh she
ordered an IPA and I was drinking ipas
at the time and I thought that was like
really really cool and then we just we
hung out and we trapped we chat we we
chatted for like I don't know five hours
six hours that night
um and uh so kind of like a classic sort
of like met at a bar kind of thing
um but can I ask you a question did you
write your own vows uh we actually
agreed to not do vows we but we but um
we did but I did end up doing like not a
speech but it's just uh you know when we
got married two days before we
technically got married
um two days before our reception or
ceremony where everyone came to we
legally got married
um we we climbed the tallest mountain in
Vermont and then we were lost we got
lost on the mountain for uh probably an
hour hour and a half or so and uh I was
so mad at her I was so like we're lost
on your wedding on our wedding day she's
got the she's got the Gown thing she's
like yeah she's got the Gap she's got
the [ __ ] Veil thing
I've got a shirt that looks like a
tuxedo and um I was like I just kept
seeing it I was like we're going to be
in the paper we're going it's gonna be
like this they're gonna find our bodies
and it's gonna be like this we have no
reception wherever we are where we had
to repel at one point we can't we had to
go through a uh how many people have
repelled on their wedding day crazy man
I was so mad at her I was so so mad at
her and then we did the ceremony at the
top I was so mad I still said I do
um
no it was it was the two of us we had a
we had our parents or my my parents her
parents my grandparents her her best
friend and her and her boyfriend and
then uh the the guy who married us and
uh Donner party out there yeah yeah it
was crazy but they drove up they drove
up to where it was they drove up but it
was just the two it was just the two of
us and the and the camera guy there was
like we had a camera guy and I and I
just I couldn't not see the headline in
my head I was so mad at her
um and she just kept saying like no
we're we're seven minutes away we're
seven minutes away and um and uh that
went on for a good 50 minutes an hour or
so and then we finally made it to the
top and um and then two days later I you
know when we were at the ceremony I just
kind of Revisited that and was just like
you know talking about you know just
that that kind of experience and uh it
was a that was a cool thing well our our
wedding we didn't anything that you
would normally do traditionally in a
wedding we uh we spent it we put it like
on its ears so like you know like we had
like a flower wall but like there were
like dildos in it and stuff like that
and we did uh you know yeah we did like
a scavenger hunt we we hired a
choreographer so we could rehearse like
a like a really cool dance with like a
medley of songs like hip-hop like stuff
so we we hired a choreographer for a few
months and did that before that nobody
knew about and we had a dunk tank at our
wedding a dunk tank yeah hell yeah I
just taught my daughter about dunk tank
yeah we were in Ocean City Maryland I'm
like back in the day there used to be a
guy dressed like a clown and he would
say the most offensive horrific [ __ ] and
you would try to dunk them and if you
didn't it got worse and then that
[ __ ] had to run for his life
when his shift was over
yeah man that's that is so good oh God
you have to make that a joke Ryan you
remember those people yeah that was a
job for a while yeah yeah get up and be
racist the shit's sexiest they would
just yell anything else yeah like I
guess he's okay because he's sitting on
a board over the water yeah and he's in
pain yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I guess it's okay that he's racist
because I can dunk him I can get them
wet that's
you can't cancel someone if they're wet
absolutely you can say whatever you want
to [ __ ] but you better get wet
after that
[ __ ] homie hurry up I just said the
n-word oh that's so funny
oh that's so good oh
okay we're about that time
um okay okay but before we wrap up I I
gave you a heads up before I want to ask
you now all right because it's
interesting because the age that this
happens and everything I'm curious what
advice you would give to 16 year old
Drew
uh it doesn't it doesn't go to it
doesn't go according to plan I know that
that's a cliche probably for a reason oh
really I don't think one person yeah it
doesn't go according to plan so
someone's gonna [ __ ] edit nine people
saying that together like Ryan you're an
[ __ ] yeah but no yeah it doesn't go
according to plan I know that's right on
the nose for me but I am I'm a
perfectionist someone who also I deeply
struggle with imposter syndrome as well
so
uh it just being okay with it not you
know like kind of like we talked about
during this podcast just like you know
there's there is Beauty in something
that is imperfect and there is
perfection in something that's not so uh
that's kind of what I would say yeah
yeah that's great this is a great
episode thank you I really do appreciate
come on and talking about I'm sure it's
not easy and I didn't know people
doubted [ __ ] like that's not not a if
it's not enough already and you gotta
deal with that [ __ ] Whispers and all
that nonsense well you know what just
[ __ ] stutter your ass all the way to
the [ __ ] Bank [ __ ] them for
real getting the finger with well you
can say [ __ ] without it that's true yeah
that's what you should have been doing
that's what I'm saying it's like I've
get I've been it's been getting like so
much better that I also in my
relationship with it has also been like
I want to make sure that I am funny
despite it or or like that it has
nothing to do with it you know I'm gonna
see this before we go yeah if
it change if you wake up one day and you
don't have the stutter anymore how will
you feel about that I'm I'm it's I think
it's becoming more and more my reality
every day it's becoming more and more
like I just don't care I don't I don't I
I the the more separation I get from it
the more it just I let it go and it's
it's just less and less and I and I I'm
I'm okay with it if there's if the
challenge then becomes oh no people
might have known me because of this or
will he will he be able to still make
jokes whatever I don't care like uh and
and I've just suffered too much
personally with it in my relationship
with it that I can't be doing I can't I
can't I can't have that relationship
it's unhealthy to constantly obsess
about uh if if and how will and how how
will I how so if there was a surgery
right now that was like hey
guaranteed 100 percent would you do it
no no no no no it's it's all about it's
all about what's happening right now and
honestly there's more uh I I hate the
word honor but I feel like the word
value there's more value in being able
to be like no you know what I did this
this is my journey and here's you can
mark it you know you can document it
good for you dude yeah that's great
thank you for coming on for real yeah
thanks for letting me talk this man it's
therapeutic to be able to like
share stuff like that well it's nice for
you to say
um please plug everything again
absolutely
um so yeah I'm doing I'm doing um San
Jose Improv that's where I'm taping it's
January 20th
um 21st and 22nd and then I'm doing
Austin Texas the week after that you can
just go to my website Drew lynch.com to
to look at any of my tour dates but um
it's mostly just the taping and I
appreciate the Drew Lynch on all Social
Security thank you so much for coming on
for real this was a pleasure
um and as always Ryan sickler on all
social media Ryan sickler.com we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]